su médico puede obtener una biopsia de
hígado para determinar la causa de la
enfermedad hepática así como la magnitud
del daño el hígado está ubicado en la
parte superior derecha del abdomen justo
debajo del diafragma se encuentra casi
totalmente dentro de la caja torácica lo
cual brinda cierta protección al órgano
el hígado es fundamental para la
digestión y el metabolismo sus diversas
funciones incluyen producir bilis que es
necesaria para la absorción de grasas
producir proteínas a partir de los
aminoácidos acumular grasas para su
almacenamiento o transporte en la sangre
regular los niveles de azúcar en la
sangre y procesar sustancias tales como
el alcohol y las drogas
es posible que se indique una biopsia de
hígado para determinar la causa de
pruebas de función hepática anormales
hinchazón o agrandamiento del hígado e
ictericia la decoloración amarillenta de
la piel y el blanco de los ojos que se
desarrolla cuando la bilirrubina
shericka se encuentra elevada usualmente
la bilirrubina es metabolizada por el
hígado estas señales y síntomas pueden
presentarse debido a diversas
condiciones hepáticas que incluyen
cirrosis hepatitis
o cáncer
antes del procedimiento se le colocará
una vía intravenosa y posiblemente se la
administre un sedante para ayudarlo a
relajarse la biopsia del hígado se
realiza con anestesia local por lo que
usted estará despierto durante el
procedimiento se le pedirá que se eche
boca arriba con el brazo derecho encima
de su cabeza deberá mantenerse lo más
quieto posible durante el procedimiento
el pulmón derecho y la vesícula se
encuentran cerca del hígado y moverse
podría dañar estos órganos su médico
determinará la ubicación de su hígado
por medio de un ultrasonido o golpeando
suavemente su abdomen con las yemas de
sus dedos
después de limpiar el área del lugar de
la biopsia con un antiséptico su médico
inyectar a anestesia local para
adormecer la piel y la superficie del
hígado una vez que la piel esté
adormecida su médico realizará un
pequeño corte con un bisturí quirúrgico
es ahí donde se introducirá la aguja su
médico hará avanzar con cuidado la aguja
de biopsia hacia la superficie del
hígado luego su médico le pedirá que
aguante la respiración mientras hace
avanzar la aguja hacia el interior del
hígado y obtiene la muestra del tejido
tan pronto como se obtenga la biopsia
usted podrá respirar con normalidad es
posible que tenga una sensación
momentánea en su hombro derecho durante
justo después de la biopsia algunos
pacientes sienten dolor y necesitan
medicamentos adicionales los cuales son
provistos por su médico en caso sea
necesario luego se aplicará presión en
el lugar de la biopsia para detener
cualquier sangrado y se le colocará una
venda en la incisión deberá recostarse
sobre su lado derecho por lo menos
durante una hora después de la biopsia
después del procedimiento se controlará
de cerca su presión sanguínea y ritmo
cardíaco después de recostarse sobre su
lado derecho por una hora o dos se le
pedirá que se eche boca arriba por lo
menos durante tres horas adicionales las
biopsias de hígado se consideran
procedimientos ambulatorios si no hay
complicaciones se le dará de alta entre
4 y 8 horas después del procedimiento